he is ranked in the top 10
of saber players
in the world
so i am very very happy to introduce
dan
hello everyone hopefully everything is
working it seems like it is um small
correction it is not uh just saber it's
beat saber so it's even less or even
more nerdier than um
what it sounds like
so um hello everyone
uh
how do i make this not do this
there we go
um
so today i finally get to talk about
some of my actual
academic research for the first time in
the length
that the art conference has existed
um so i like to start off with thanking
my community chair um ann brown who
has
who is an assistant professor and holds
positions in the biochemistry and
university libraries where she studies
both molecular modeling and drug design
and also
runs a data science program through the
university library
and the rest of my committee uh dave
higdon who is the staffs of the virginia
tech stats department the chair of the
virginia tech stats department
alex hanlon who runs the biostats
department and nikki lewis who does a
lot of educational research in the
honors college
and with that a little bit of my mouse
about myself
so this past february i passed my
prelims so i am now a phd candidate
studying data science education and
pedagogy specifically in the medical
biomedical and health sciences
in 2019 i was one of the r studio
interns working on the great dis
lerner
great this which is an auto code grader
for learner documents if you use it any
time now pretty much none of the code
that i worked on exists because uh
garrett sort of uh rewrote the entire
package so
and a lot of my dissertation work comes
from me being a software carpentry
instructor from 2014 so i'm really lucky
to be able to
do a dissertation around things that i
have experience in
and i also teach workshops and do my
work in both r and python
so a little bit about the educational
materials um that i've worked on
like jared mentioned i authored a book
called pandas for everyone
from the pearsons safari perspective um
there's a bunch of video
courses that i have but what i want to
talk about today is this project that's
related to my dissertation which is
called data science for biomedical
sciences
and so a little bit about current data
science education
data science education is everywhere it
is essentially
very free and it's a commodity and
really content isn't an issue but what
really is lacking is
courses or things being really explicit
focusing on data products and data
cleaning so if you look at this chart
here on the left there are a lot of n a
blocks that
should be filled in
and so why do we care about
um
domain specificity well
because there are so much data science
materials then we have the ability to
make introductory data science materials
more specific to domains and make it
more accessible to a wider range of
domains
so and another another way you can think
of it also is you learn better when
things are more relevant and that helps
with a lot of internal motivation and
creating good feedback loops as you're
learning something new
[Music]
and so
as we if we think about
how to create these domain specific
materials you should first need to think
about who are our learners
and so
our learners if we think want to think
about who our our learners are we want
to be able to know what they already
know and there are a few ways that you
can sort of map out
what do they know
one way you can do is given a specific
topic you can draw out what is called a
concept map which is essentially a bunch
of nodes and edges about how topics
relate to one another if you don't like
concept maps there's another
exercise you can do it's called task
deconstruction
and essentially your learners
fall under this spectrum
known as the dreyfus model skill
acquisition
and depending on whether they're a
novice a practitioner or an expert
really relates to how dense that node of
knowledge is and how well that they're
connected to one another
and so for the work that i work on
we created a workshop survey which i
would
if you are thinking about doing
something like this for yourself
there are surveys that you can take and
it's really based off of a combination
of the carpentry surveys stuff from how
learning works and
survey examples from teaching tech
together
and so the surveys that i gave out or
had people take
there are eight sections and
four of them which are highlighted in
orange are the ones that we use to
figure out who our learners are by
clustering them together
so we took those four
core questions uh we
clustered them together and then i found
out that they essentially create four
different groups and then if you look at
the demographic information you've
sort of deduced that they fall under
expert clinician academic and student
and so we use that information to create
a set of personas and so
we have claire de clinician samir the
student patricia the programmer and alex
the academic and if you want you can go
to that url to get a more detailed view
of each persona
specifically what is a learner persona
it is a fictional character that you
create that is based off of real data
but it incorporates their background
information prior relevant knowledge and
experience perception of needs and any
special considerations and this way when
you start thinking about learning
materials or your audience you can now
say oh what would claire need in this
scenario versus
trying to recreate a persona on the fly
you can now talk to other team members
or other collaborators and be like this
wouldn't work for claire because of
blank
and so once we have the learning
percentage how do we go about planning
the actual learning materials
so the learning materials that i have
created um there are eight learning
objectives
most of them are going to be centralized
around the concept of tidy data and data
literacy concepts and the way i
structured it and it came out of the
surveys was if we can structure or get
people to think about what is a clean or
tidy data set then it's much easier to
learn all of the other data analysis
stuff
and another thing that i also realized
that a lot of my learners or maybe your
learners as well come from the world of
spreadsheets and so we need to be able
to get them from the world of excel
into some system like r to do their work
um more efficiently or more reproducibly
in a more reproducible manner but at the
same time we don't want to say like you
can't do any of your work in excel there
are times and places where that's using
spreadsheet software is useful
so these learning objectives are based
off of bloom's
taxonomy which is a hierarchy of verbs
that
sort of
help you guide creating these learning
objectives right and the whole point of
creating these learning objectives is
because we want to be able to assess are
these workshop materials quote unquote
effective and so how do you define
effective you create learning objectives
and a lot of that goes down to bloom's
taxonomy
so when you go about creating your
learning objectives you see this
hierarchy of
terms
that build on a particular skill but the
thing you want to keep in mind
especially and as you're building
materials and teaching is that you don't
really teach one layer at a time and go
to the next layer uh for example i can
teach you how to load a data set into r
and like do some filtering et cetera et
cetera and then i ask you to apply that
skill to another topic but then you can
cycle back down and say like okay now
that you know how to get the data you
want let's go and show you the
uh code to save it out to a separate
data set so you can do your work in
excel and sort of build on existing
skills so even though bloom's taxonomy
shows up as a hierarchy
it's a good practice to don't teach your
materials one layer at a time and it's
very sick
it's very circular
and so a lot of the stuff that i worked
on
or work on is focused around tidy data
and so we've all seen
allison horst's illustrations
tidy data sets are all alike but every
messy data set is messy in their own way
and so this is an example from hadley
wickham's tidy data paper as an example
if we for example look at
this 52 it represents the
tuberculosis count for a particular
country and year
and if we look at the column names it
stands for a particular
sex and age group so that 52 has a
problem because that number
encodes two bits of information it
encodes gender and
age group
and so we wouldn't be able to do
something
like
uh what uh what is the total count for
all um
people in the 0 to 14 age group right
because now we have to look at two
columns we can't do something like a
group by and a summarize or sum
something like that
and so to make this data tidy we
first melt the data or pivot longer the
data into the version on the left and
then we can say uh use
heuristics to figure out oh how do we
clean up that column well if we pop out
the first letter we can use that for sex
and then the rest can be used for age
group and now we have a tidy data set
and then we can do group by operations
or fitting models or make plots etc etc
and so this view between long data and
wide data
or however whatever terminal terminology
you want to use
i think is really critical especially if
you're coming from the world of excel
and especially if you're using
spreadsheet programs as a method for
data entry if you are a clinician trying
to do a retrospective chart review and
so if you know going in that if i
collect data in one format because it's
easier for me to collect i can encode or
some other way pivot this data so the
computer can understand it so it can do
the rest of my analysis that's really
important
and so one of the questions that i give
during the
end of the workshop so this is called a
summative
assessment question like a quote unquote
final question is this this question
where let's say you're given this data
set about
cyclomegalovirus
and it's really only a problem um if you
are
immunocompromised or pregnant and how do
you
go about fitting a model or doing some
kind of analysis knowing that there are
other variables in this data set that
relate to the
variable of interest
and so if we go through this example
what are the bits and pieces that
someone who is given that data set would
need to learn well the first thing they
need to learn is how to load up
different libraries we are using tidy
verse just for its consistency for the
introductory workshop
and then we also need to load up the
read excel library because tidyverse
doesn't load up everything so they have
to know about how to load up other tools
in r
and then if we look at the simple line
of code that is read excel
gets saved into a variable called that
well there's a lot of things going on
there the even the
even the path to the file requires them
to have some knowledge of a
what is a working directory what is the
difference between a working directory
and a full path they have to be able to
know
how to make function calls and this read
excel comes from the read excel package
they have to know the assignment
operator they have to know about saving
things to a variable and so there's a
lot of things going on into what
i would consider as a proficient r user
as a very simple thing but when you're
teaching there is a lot of things going
on
so what's the next skill that they would
probably need to do well um they might
need to filter their data set for
some other criteria so maybe they only
care about
people over 65 because they're trying to
use some of this data for
medicare data et cetera et cetera and so
we teach them um the next function
but in doing that we also have to go
cover pipes and then filtering data and
what is a boolean condition
after that
to go around with good data practices or
integrate their work into
spreadsheet life
how do you save out this stuff into an
excel sheet so at least part of your
data pipeline is reproducible and so now
we have to show a another function that
does something else we have to show them
we sort of go back and say like hey
remember you can always save these
intermediates into other outputs
and then we've used this other function
to save this out into excel file and
then they can carry on or give that to
another colleague or if they don't know
how to do plotting yet
they can plot their data but then this
way if the data set updates they don't
have to worry about that part of the
analysis
the next thing so i focus a lot around
tidy data concepts how do we go from
data set to the left to the data set on
the right well then they're gonna have
to know about
uh lists vectors or different ways you
can uh select code so that's like tidy
select in the r r example
um you have to recognize is this a
pivot longer or pivot wider operation or
melt uh cast operation in python it's
going to be melt and pivot table et
cetera et cetera they're going to have
to identify that
and then at the end they might want to
do a little bit of cleanup so i show
them the drop n a function or you might
need to drop missing variables just so
you have a clean data set
from the plotting perspective so we go
back to say hey plotting is another
library so here's ggplot2 there is the
plotting syntax that uses pluses instead
of a piping notation but what's really
important in the context of ggplot is
the entire system of how layers work so
we have our data layer our mapping layer
where we put our aesthetic and then we
have a stats layer and then a geometry
layer etc etc or a theme layer and that
all of that information needs to get
conveyed
on top of that
you also have to show them that
different variables in our data set
use different types of plots it for
example it wouldn't make sense to create
a scatter plot of just the column of
eight right we need two
continuous variables to create a scatter
plot
and then last but not least how do we go
about fitting a model
i have a background in epidemiology and
public health and one of the core
methods that we use is logistic
regression so i sort of
show them
our learners logistic regression because
most of my learners or my audience is
people or are people in the health
sphere
once you fit the model
you have to know or in order to fit a
model you have to know about this
formula syntax and then the rest of the
bits and pieces to
put your information into a function so
that's a little bit of a review
looking at your model results now we
have to use a summary function how do
you interpret it
how do you get the coefficients out as a
data frame so there's another library we
can use broom and a tidy function from
broom to get our coefficient table
and then we can go back to some of the
stuff we learned in the very beginning
when we were exploring data
where in order to interpret logistic
regression output we actually have to
exponentiate our coefficients and
interpret them as odds ratios instead of
log odds and so there's another bit of
information or another data process that
they would have to do in order to
interpret their coefficients
and so a big part of this and some of
the things i guess like i found the
words to describe it is
data science is different from computer
science education
but what exactly makes it different
and
if we look for example at a typical
computer science question um this is
asking you about binary search from a
five element array
i can read you this question i can read
this question i still have no idea what
this question is asking for but i'm sure
if you have a formal computer science
education uh this will make more sense i
also remember
taking uber in san francisco many years
ago and literally like got interview
questions in the uber ride and was
around stuff like this which isn't data
science related
and so
this is why um this is one of the
differences between
computer science and data science but
then what is fundamentally the
difference here
well
what i think is
in a lot of computer science courses
that you take a data frame object isn't
really a data structure that you learn
about you pretty much learn about lists
and then everything goes around lists if
you're in a python world then you learn
about dictionaries and and all of that
stuff um so that's why stuff like
indexing and for loops and all of that
become
core computer science education topics
but if you look at the r for data
science book like iteration and for
loops are like at the very end of the
book it's almost like if you're working
with a data frame object this probably
your last resort or you don't really
need to do this because you can apply
things apply functions on a data frame
and so because a data frame is so
fundamental to
data science
the way data science needs to get taught
should be different or the ordering of
topics should be different from computer
science education
at the end of the day a lot of the stuff
from a typical intro computer science
class probably will you'll learn as a
data science but it's really about this
ordering ordering and trying to make the
beginning easier for people to pick up
and so if we compare
existing books so there's offer data
science
outside so we saw this morning from
danielle's talk
you can use data visualization as a
means to drive or motivate people
since some most of the stuff that i'm
working on this is all workshop
materials i'm going to sort of assume
that
you are already self-motivated enough to
attend this workshop so i don't need to
motivate you more in the beginning
because you are signing up for a
workshop so that's why i can push tidy
data principles higher because i'm
saving um some of that time from
plotting for later on
but from r for data science they put
plotting first some workflow stuff and
then they also do tidy data pretty fast
if you uh filter down that um table of
contents for the things that are
actually like chapters there's another
book data science for javascript that's
written by greg wilson toby hodges and
maya gans
they are teaching
javascript so you'll see in the
beginning of this book it's a lot of dom
manipulation like traditional javascript
stuff and then the actual data
manipulation stuff happens towards the
end um that is sort of like a
uh
style and you're just assuming that like
wait we actually need to teach like
something that shows up on the browser
before we actually load in the data set
so they know what they're doing so i can
get that and then the ultra open intro
statistics textbook doesn't really cover
tidy data principles in the beginning
but at least they are setting up
fundamental data principles
for a statistics context
from the python world you have wes's
python for data analysis book and if you
sort of like go past the first 150 pages
which is the first four four and a half
chapters um
it
it essentially covers data wrangling
which is that pivoting operation really
fast it's essentially the second chapter
in the book um learning the pandas
library is a book by
matt harrison and
he comes from a computer science
background so there's a lot of stuff
about just the actual data structure
about
data frames and
series and then eventually we go into
processing data with pivoting and tidy
data stuff
and then for the stuff that i work on in
pandas for everyone
tidy data comes up as chapter six and
that's also because this is supposed to
be a more general book so i try to put
plotting as early as i can and that's
why plotting ends up being chapter three
in ds4 biomed
the materials are central uh the first
thing i need to get is let's start with
spreadsheets and get your spreadsheet
correct i essentially teach tidy data
principles in spreadsheets they just
don't know it yet and then by
chapter six or part six of the book we
actually show you like the the ways you
can fix up spreadsheets if that's the
way you're inputting data and then if i
were to teach a conference workshop i
literally just throw tidy data as a
second thing
this is also because there's a huge time
constraint in conference workshop so
that is uh the second thing i show you
because it's more
i would say it's like a harder topic to
grasp and that's why that just gets
pushed up to the very top
and so
what do i want you to get out of this
talk um
identify if you do end up creating your
own set of learning materials identify
who your learners are figure out what
they want to know and then plan a guided
learning track and then the way you can
sort of
figure out what your learners know you
can if you want use this survey that i
have created um what's next or really
like what is the rest of my dissertation
that i need to finish by december um is
the actual survey validation for this so
it actually becomes a validated tool for
other people to use um there is
all of that stuff that i talked about
learning objectives and how do we um
assess them um there are pre-post stuff
so there are
workshops that are involved uh which i
will post into the conference chat right
after my talk that if you want you can
sign up for and then there's also a
long-term retention
uh component to this like if i teach you
this now do you
is it useful enough that you stick with
it or have you used it four months six
months down the line and then there's
another thing that sort of builds on the
stuff that i worked on with grade this
about different types of formative
assessments like if i were to ask you a
question in the middle of class should i
give you a question and a blank
canvas like a blank text box or should i
fill in and have you fill in like um
blanks for code that works
um for additional resources so there's
carawoo's
spreadsheet paper if you want to learn
about personas there's some links about
personas and if you are an educator
there are some introductory stuff about
bloom's taxonomy and like teaching
techniques of how to
sort of put words to
what teachers do in the classroom
so with that thank you everyone the
slides and links and repositories are
all posted up on github and if you
really want you can read the prelim that
i um have successfully like gone through
in february there's a link to that as
well
great thank you very much dan
and i can't believe the first morning is
already over
before we go to lunch